we were at war when I was press
secretary so things are also different
but let's say something was happening
and it was a national security issue and
somebody within the government suggested
I say such and such answer at the
briefing well when I did because I was a
reporter by training is I would
double-check and triple-check so I had
my deputies and I would say Gordon can
you call the national security council
see if this is what they say Tony's
gonna call DoD you call the CIA let's
meet back here in 20 minutes and if
everybody has the same answer I'll say
it at the podium and if we don't then I
would go to the chief of staff's office
and I'd say we've got a problem here
because everybody's not settled and we
have to get this right because people's
lives are on the line this thing about
that you needed sort of this unforced
break do you do you think a lot of
people are suddenly feeling that like
just the way life is and how fast
everything seems to move in social media
and the 24-hour news cycle that you're
well aware of that we suddenly got this
break and of course it's not for a good
reason but that but basically if you're
okay right now and you've got a roof
over your head and hopefully you have a
couple bucks that there really is an
incredible opportunity to kind of look
at your life and look at the world a
little bit differently absolutely if you
read any anyone saying like what what do
you really want in your life or what
it's that people feel over busy I made a
new year's resolution that when people
said how are you doing that's a couple
years ago that I would stop saying I'm
so busy because everybody is so busy
everybody is trying and striving and
doing nobody says oh I'm fine totally
kicked back I get eight hours of sleep a
night everything's good everybody has
stuff so I stopped saying that a couple
of years ago and that was a good sort of
mental shift for me and I but I know it
in myself I have a very hard time saying
no to opportunities that come my way
everything is amazing
in New York City would you you know
would you speak at this event for this
wonderful charity but what about for
this veterans group and I I can be out
weeknights every single night of the
week and then trying to catch up on life
on the weekends and what I've realized
is that you having to tap the brakes
because we have to all do our part in
this pandemic it's been it's been
actually really good for me and I don't
have I know that I can't hold on to this
completely when all of us return to
normal but I would like to figure out a
way that I could hold on to a little bit
of it because I I it is better for me a
lot better yeah well it's interesting
it's one of the reasons why I like doing
your show because even though you're
doing informational stuff you're doing
like the daily grind political stuff
like there is this other feeling that I
think you have that a lot of shows kind
of miss which is that there's something
that's going on in the world at all
times that doesn't have to do with
politics exactly and I think for you
guys one of the cool things for me over
the last couple years is I've gotten to
know I would say you Greg Gutfeld who's
a good buddy of yours and Tucker Carlson
specifically it's like when we watch you
guys there's something a little bit
different about watching someone on
cable news then on the internet like
it's almost like are these people actual
humans and I think you've been able to
now show that window like oh there's a
human here here's the dog we're real
people that has been nice during this
but you know it's interesting I give
Greg Gutfeld a ton of credit for
actually bringing me along on that
because we started the 5:00 in July of
2011 and before that I'd been the press
secretary and that's a pretty serious
job and even though I was in the public
eye I didn't do a ton of personal things
like I would well we didn't have
Instagram or Twitter then so I I didn't
really share my life because I thought
who would care well then we start doing
the five and we would be asked in what
do you think about this and almost
always I was instinctively giving the
answer as if I was still the White House
press secretary for george w bush and at
one point greg said no what do you think
and it was about drug legalization
marijuana legalization I've never smoked
pot I'm not into it I have a very
unpopular opinion I don't think it's
good idea but I realized I just froze
and I had never given my total opinion
about anything out loud and he pushed me
a little and teased me a little and made
it okay for me to kind of just more be
myself and not have to be the press
secretary so much anymore and so I get
asked an interview sometimes is there
something that people don't know about
you
nope like it's been 10 years we've been
doing the five and I was yeah there is
pretty much nothing people don't know
about me so Greg actually really helps
with that and then especially on the
five we take our we we take the news
seriously but we don't take ourselves
that seriously and life is life can be
sweet and God meant for us to be joyous
and I haven't really learned that from
President George Bush too we worked very
hard but we were always celebrating the
joys of getting a chance to serve at the
highest levels of government for the
best country the world's ever seen
yeah so all right let's back up to that
for a second so for the people that
don't know you just reference but you
were press secretary for George W Bush
that means you're the person I remember
watching you back in the day really sure
parents yeah yeah your answer and you're
answering or at least to the best of the
ability of a press secretary answering a
lot of tough questions related to
foreign policy and the economy and all
kinds of stuff can you give me like some
insight into what that job was like then
versus maybe how it is now I mean Trump
barely has to use a secretary press
secretary because that's just kind of
out there and and then the network's now
CNN doesn't even cover those things
anymore
you guys cover it but how that sort of
has changed over you know it's been
about what 20 years or so 15 years it's
interesting in January of 2009 so
January 20th 2009 the Bush's turn things
over to the Obamas I was there for the
last day and then Peter I left for
Africa
we went to South Africa for two weeks
vacation and two weeks volunteering at a
PEPFAR site and I really I wanted that
time to reset my priorities reset my
marriage reset my brain and to get ready
for this transition but I think back on
that and I didn't even have a Twitter
account at that point and if you think
just that was 2009 think in 10 years how
things change so dramatically and you
think about the Obama campaign that
absolutely smoked the Republicans on
social media in 2008 campaign and then
in 2016 president Trump realizes that he
can talk directly to people and he was
very comfortable with that I don't know
if George Bush ever would sometimes I
laugh and think about writing a book of
tweets Bush would have sent but I am it
has changed so much like now I will say
this I think for the country briefings
from the press secretary I always tried
to turn down the temperature in the room
I thought why are we fighting I'm here
to give information you're here to
elicit information
I always remember too that those
reporters have a job to do and part of
my job as press secretary I believed was
protecting their right to have access to
the government and but here's the other
thing I truly believe that a press
briefing a daily press briefing forces a
White House to have really good process
because if they know that the press
secretary is gonna have to go out there
and she's gonna have to answer all
answered these questions and that mean
you better her back first if there's
problems and the policy isn't settled
everybody needs to get on the phone and
get it done and thing I used to do was
let's say I was good we were at war when
I was press secretary so things are also
different but let's say something was
happening and it was a national security
issue and somebody within the government
suggested I say such-and-such answer at
the briefing well when I did because I
was a reporter by training is I would
double-check and triple-check so I had
my deputies
I would say Gordon can you call the
national security council see if this is
what they say Tony's gonna call DoD you
call the CIA let's meet back here in 20
minutes
and if everybody has the same answer
I'll say it at the podium and if we
don't then I would go to the chief of
staff's office and I'd say we've got a
problem here because everybody's not
settled and we have to get this right
because people's lives are on the line
so in that case I feel like forcing good
process is really good but everything's
changed so much who knows if it'll ever
go back to being a daily press briefing
no the president well we just finished
he does he does him now I think we're
starting to enjoy it in the briefing
room well he's having a hell of a time
and they're clearly I mean I from the
little bit that I can you know I don't
have time either to watch these huge
things in there talking they're in their
totality but when I watch them I'm like
yeah he's actually having fun if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlists all right
over here and to get notified of all
future videos be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell